oh wait Ezra morning oh pretty good
pretty good i killed a hooker
accidentally mind you I back over my
pickup truck then I took her money so it
all you know it all worked out soon
theft auto me too oh no random photo for
videos next week this week is a boom
blox and mario kart for the week but oh
yeah i needed to ask you don't really
know what i can say out here there's a
dead hooker in the bathroom right now
can you help me chop her up I don't know
how to use this thing that's our kohler
haha seriously though dead hooker
bathroom yeah
hi everybody i'm chris kohler and i'm
sitting here with a mere rahimi and he's
the senior producer on boom blox a new
game for the Wii coming out very soon
from Electronic Arts essentially boom
blox is a game that was built from the
ground up for the Nintendo Wii and we
really wanted to take full advantage of
the wii controls um and it's being
developed in collaboration with Academy
award-winning director and producer
Steven Spielberg she and this really
surprised me at first because when it
was announced that Steven Spielberg was
going to be working with EA you know I
think we all fought about cinematic
video games you know Jurassic Park the
video game meaty you know um and and yet
this game really seems kind of like
something that would come out of
Nintendo it's very much a puzzle game
it's not really what you'd what you
think yeah it's really a true video game
and I think we'd be able to some extent
were a little bit surprised but when you
really you know sit down and play the
game you start to see sort of spilt
spielberg's genius come through i mean
what part of what makes Spielberg
Spielberg is his ability to understand
what moves people what sort of
universally compelling and that ability
really transferred well from film to
video games his idea was to build a game
that tees off on a compulsion that just
about everybody on the planet is that at
some point to build something up whether
it's you know blocks in this case or you
know a sand castle or coke bottles or
dominoes whatever and then have fun just
smashing them to the ground there's
there's a whole lot get to do we've
developed a very realistic physics
simulator so when you interact with
these blocks they they really move
realistically and we've built on almost
400 levels lots of different game modes
around that experience the first thing
we teach the players had a throw that's
one of the major actions of boom blox
you get to get to throw all sorts of you
know crazy wacky objects at blocks and
the the thrill mechanic takes full
advantage of the we
no so how hard you throw for example
really matters and and again since the
physics are so realistic there's a
certain layer of strategy that factors
interviewing walks that really offsets
the sort of superficial fun of just
knocking stuff over so the angle at
which you aim that how hard you throw
which block and choose to throw at
really matters and people who sort of
our good a billiards or understand
billiards tend to gravitate towards a
lot of game modes and in blocks the game
can be played a single player in a
multiplayer both competitively and
cooperatively and then we also have a
create mode which allows players to take
any one of the almost 400 levels that
exist in the game pull them into the
create mode and do anything they want to
them or they can build their own sort of
levels or no Domino trails or incredible
machines from scratch Lemire thank you
very much for being here today sure
thank you for your time and we are going
to be playing boom box on may six 2008
all right let's go Nintendo's pushed to
make gaming accessible to everyone in
the family is seen by a lot of people as
a recent invention but for me the Mario
Kart series has been the original and
best bring the family together game my
brother my parents and I would all sit
around and play the original super mario
kart for hours and that was before it
was for player my mom would actually sit
and wait her turn to play battle mode
since then the Mario Kart series has
been a staple of multiplayer fun on
Nintendo consoles it's a brilliant
combination of racing and fighting as
you and your friends race go-karts along
outrageous courses you're collecting
items like turtle shells and speed
boosting mushrooms and firing them at
each other it's always been great fun so
mario kart wii has a lot to live up to
now let me tell you something guys it
doesn't it doesn't live up to it at all
in attempting to make Mario Kart
accessible to the masses they've killed
it for the hardcore mario kart wii
includes the Wii wheel now you take the
wii remote like this and insert it right
into the wheel like so now it yes it's
just an inner piece of plastic but what
it lets you do is gives you a lot more
stability when you're turning the wii
remote like this to drive and
since it's actually okay it does what
it's supposed to it's not an abject
piece of crap like the Wii zapper it
works but okay doesn't mean recommended
yes the Wii wheel is much more likely to
get your aging maiden aunt Tilly to get
out of a rocking chair and try one of
those newfangled videogame contraptions
and for that it's a good idea but if
you're a gamer you're going to get much
more precision by using the standard
wiimote nunchuck combo you can also use
the gamecube controller but there's a
reason not to to pull off tricks in this
version of mario kart you shake the wii
controller to do the same thing on the
gamecube controllers which don't have
motion sensing you have to take your
thumb off the joystick and hit a button
which is not optimal now these tricks
which you execute when your character
goes off a rap and gets air aren't just
for show they give you a speed boost so
if you want to win you have to be
constantly doing tricks you can also get
speed boosts by drifting as you go
around corners now in all previous Mario
Kart games you had to do some precise
little joystick movements to get the
speed boosts meaning that it required
some skill oh not in mario kart wii now
you just have to hold down the button
and the speed boost come automatically
still will still get you far in a
multiplayer game but now that the
learning curve has been so flattened out
everybody's going to be as good as you
are with only a little bit of practice
expert players are going to have to
start selecting characters and vehicles
that are more difficult to handle but
faster for example mario kart wii for
the first time introduces motorbikes
into the series but it's honestly not
the single player game that killed mario
kart wii for me this series for my
friends and my family and me has always
been about the battle mode now you don't
race in battle mode you drive around and
open arena firing items at each other
mario kart wii killed battle mode i
don't know why but the traditional Last
Man Standing battles are gone replaced
with a time-based mode in which
everybody gets to play until time runs
out and players are always put onto two
teams meaning that if you're playing
with three it's going to be uneven
there's no free for all I imagine this
might have been done because that's the
only way they could get it to work with
their new
online multiplayer mode now the online
play works great by the way up to 12
people from all over the world can
battle or race each other even though
Nintendo's traditional lack of voice
chat still cripples the potential fun
you know but even if the online works
okay why did they have to kill the
offline mode to make it work you know I
don't even mind the changes Nintendo
made to the single player game I don't
even mind the Wii wheel but I do mind
opening mario kart wii up getting ready
to play it with my friends and finding
out that basically the one reason we
wanted to play it the best feature of
the series over the last 15 years has
been taken out into the back and shot
and that's why i can only give mario
kart wii a 6 out of 10